licencié à l' us sochaux le jeune garçon
ont participé avec son club un tournoi
de football en salle
dans ce gymnase de beaucourt hier après
midi lorsqu'il a été pris d'un malaise
il n'y a pas eu de choc
l'enfant a été rapidement prise en
charge il a été rapidement pris en
compte par des parents qui étaient
présents sur place dont l'un était un
pompier en vendée je crois et l'autre
une dame qui était infirmière ils ont
été il a été du tout pris en compte il a
été on est équipé avec un défibrillateur
dont ils ont fait le nécessaire précis
de 2 2 ramené de de faire de choquer
voilà et malheureusement ça n'a pas
fonctionné l'hélicoptère du dragon de
colmar qui était semble-t-il en vole pas
très loin d'ici est arrivé très
rapidement il s'est posé derrière
en attendant de pouvoir l'évacuer
malheureusement ça
son état de santé ne le permettait pas
une enquête est en cours la municipalité
de beaucourt étudie la mise en place
possible d'une assistance psychologique
à l'adresse notamment des enfants
témoins de ce drame